[Music]
okay we're white let's play
let's play e4 this time i feel like i
feel like going e4
and
okay so he plays an alakan which i kind
of like because we haven't gotten a
chance to face the alakan i think and
in the alakine there's two main moves
against knight f6 you can play knight c3
you can play knight c3
um but that is not an ambitious move of
course because black can play e5 and
transpose into a vienna or black can
play d5 and transpose to a favorable
scandi
so of course e5 is
e5 is is really the move knight d5 and
now d4
as i'm sure you guys know and black
generally plays d6 here that's the main
line okay so this is the first
uh crossroads
this is the first crossroads
uh again white has two
principal lines here
there is knight f3 to support the pawn
and then there is the move c4 to expand
in the center
and harass the knight
if you want to play uh the most
ambitious line and if you want to strive
for a big advantage a line to play is
the four pawns attack against the alakan
the four pawns attack is a very very
dangerous system now i will say that i
don't know it too well so we're going to
play it but i don't know the theory all
that well myself because i don't
generally play it against
uh players my level so c4
and now there's e takes d6 which is the
relatively speaking more positional main
line but what we're going to play
something very explosive f4 the four
pawns attack against the alakan
considered to be one of the best lines
if not the best line
from an objective standpoint
if white knows what to do then white is
definitely uh
better
although not by too much thank you
jeremiah so here of course we play
not d take c5 which allows
an unfavorable queen trade we take
toward the center fe
and it should be clear to you guys what
the pluses and minuses of this system
are the plus of the system is that we
get a monster center the minus of the
system is that we're delaying our
development and if we don't develop
carefully our center could get under
very serious fire we could end up losing
all three of these pawns and this is the
first stage at which you simply have to
know what to do if you don't know what
to do you might play the move knight f3
and you'd be forgiven for thinking
that's the main line but it's not why is
knight f3 not great and how should we
defend this pawn instead
yeah knight f3 allows bishop g4 which
puts massive pressure on the knight and
therefore
to the pawn
no don't go d5 because that drops the e5
pawn we should go bishop to e3 that is
the only viable defensive approach
yeah d5 would drop the e5 pawn
knight f3 allows bishop g4 so we must
play bishop to e3 generally if i
remember correctly yeah bishop f5 is the
main line
and now we can develop normally now we
can first play knight c3
just developing the knight and if he
plays e6 which is the main line we play
knight to f3
and uh so we successfully have defended
our center
uh double jazzy i'll talk about that
after the game yeah so knight f3
now
black can still play bishop g4 that is
one of the main lines bishop g4 is such
an explosive move that people sometimes
waste to waste the whole tempo and still
go bishop g4 that's one of the lines uh
the black has at his disposal
another line is to play uh bishop b7 and
then prepare f6 to open up the center
that i think is the most popular
continuation
um and we're going to see what our
opponent chooses your knight to b4 may
seem a little bit scary but
it's not dangerous due to rook c1
i think maybe some of you are thinking
about knight b4 but you just have rook
c1
so let's see which line he chooses
bishop b7
now obviously white
we must complete our development
and uh
we have two squares for the bishop we
can play bishop d3
but bishop d3 weakens the pawn a little
bit it allows bishop g4
so we we should develop a little bit
more modestly here with bishop e2
so all of this is pretty natural now
usually black castles and then plays f6
in this line or f6 immediately
to chip away at white's center castles
castles
yeah and here f6 is the main move
okay
let's see if he knows it
now f6
uh opens up the center and activates
black star squared bishop on the other
hand the drawback of that move is that
the e6 bond is going to end up being
very very weak uh
once the the trade occurs
so as far as i remember i analyzed this
maybe like a year or so ago white is
better white is better but it's a very
complicated position so it's not the
kind of advantage or black doesn't have
any fun a5
yeah this move i'm not familiar with i
don't think it's a move i i mean i think
what he's trying to probably do is
expand
uh expand on the queen side but i feel
like this idea is too slow
in fact i think we can already step on
the gas pedal so to speak we have
completed our development so our center
is now very nicely defended and the move
that stems from that observation is
uh is d5 we should consider it okay so
d5 edcd
and uh that pawn is going to be defended
twice and attacked twice so he can't
take it with his knight
so after d5 edcd this knight is going to
have to move because it's under fire so
he's probably going to go
knight to b4
and that knight from b4 is going to be
putting more pressure on the d5 pawn but
in that resulting position can anybody
tell me whether white has a nice way
uh to transform the position and defend
the d5 pawn i think there's a very nice
approach there
knight d4 is interesting yes but that's
not what i'm thinking of
what i'm thinking of
not a3 a3 he's able to take the bond so
i know it's hard to visualize let's make
these moves on the board let's make
these moves on the board
bishop c4 would drop the bishop due to
the b6 knight which is still on the
board
hopefully he goes ed and knight before
so i could show my thinking process
now the moment he played a5 one
observation that i made immediately is
that the knight on b6 has lost a little
bit of support it's still defended by
the c pawn but it's no longer defended
by two pawns and so i immediately kind
of noticed the pattern that in some
positions bishop takes knight might
force him to take away from the center
and that could shift the balance
away from the center and give this
d-pawn a path forward
so you guys should already be able
you guys should begin to think about the
correct approach after night before we
play bishop b6 cb and then d6 the bishop
is almost trapped there not quite
trapped but that pawn is going to be a
total monster and i think he's kind of
realizing that here
so i i'm quite familiar with this type
of idea so it was easier for me to spot
but now you're going to be familiar with
it as well
could you play d5 before trading on well
that's what we're doing
oh could you play d6 before trading on
no because if you play d6 first then he
will simply take the pawn and then the
queen is going to be defending the
knight
yeah yeah i know i understood your
question but the answer is no
okay
so
[Music]
the movie plays is knights b4
immediately that doesn't change anything
that doesn't change anything at all i
mean he keeps uh he keeps a pair of
pawns on the board but still we play
bishop takes b6 and then d6 if anything
i think his move is probably a little
bit better because the bishop on f5 is
now anchored by the pawn
but still white is
white is basically dominating it's funny
how like the
the uh the videos where i played a
cheater are the most viewed of the
speedrun i don't know what that really
says
i guess people like the the intrigue and
the drama
maybe i should just title all of my
speedrun videos like playing a cheater
i wish that weren't the case but
it is
okay so he goes he panics
and that he shouldn't have done that i
think he's still pretty much okay if he
responds correctly but this is a classic
situation he just saw d6 and he panicked
uh so he plays he takes d5
and
of course we could play c takes d5 and
recapture but why do that when we could
simply drop the bishop back and we're up
a piece okay he can play dc but then we
play bishop c4 there's no compensation
so where should we put this bishop what
seems to be the safest square for the
bishop
where it's out of the way
of ideas like knight c2
what's the most solid square it's
definitely f2 it's nicely protected
uh we don't need to worry about the file
being closed we're already up a piece
and you know that's like winning the
lottery and saying well
um the hundred dollar bills that i'm
being handed are a little bit too
crumpled like you're already up a piece
don't worry about preserving all of the
advantages of the position
and that's a mistake that i see pretty
often so a move like bishop e3 could be
justified by the logic of trying to keep
the f file open but of course it would
succumb to the move knight c2
immediately forking the rook of the
bishop
knight d4
is unnecessarily tactical i think and in
fact i think it would be a blunder
because if we had gone knight t4 to
counter attack the bishop and he simply
drops the bishop back
that bishop on b6
is going to be trapped because the
knight is going to be blocking its way
back
so we should just keep things very solid
here
bishop f2
if i have calculated it correctly i'm
not sure
always retreat
all right
so already the game is basically over uh
not only is he down a piece but look at
how well coordinated all of our pieces
are they're nicely positioned in the
center and that on b4 is not dangerous
we could always kick it away
go c6 so speaking of taking it away
let me ask you guys a question is a3
knight c2 dangerous for white should we
perhaps go rook c1 first or knight t4
first or is it okay to allow that
the knight is trapped yeah it's totally
fine to allow knight c2 because we play
rook c1 and then we can simply take on
c2 yeah now of course we can play cd and
knight takes d5
i anticipate he might resign
so we can play knight t5 we could also
play queen takes d5 centralizing the
queen and offering a queen trade i
actually quite like queen takes d5 i
feel like it
it also connects the rooks which is nice
and perhaps this knight could sink its
teeth onto b5 later let's stick with the
queen let's keep things very open and
simple it doesn't matter knight d5 would
have been perfectly fine too
as i always say don't overthink these
kinds of low-level decisions it's not
worth spending more than 10-15 seconds
on them because even if there is a
marginal difference
it's just not worth the extra time if
you're playing a rapid game
yeah so we're now a full piece of
there's there isn't even any pawns
how should we proceed in a position like
this
what seems to be the most clinical
pathway
to converting this
so i propose activating
excellent everybody getting getting the
answer right centralizing the rook plus
but this rook on c1 let's put the other
rook on d1 both rooks on open files
and he is totally paralyzed completely i
mean not a single piece can consent he's
probably going to go bishop e6 or like
bishop e4 but then we could still go
rook fd1
yeah there should be four
we could still go rook fd1 defending the
night we don't need to move the knight
he is welcome to trade
who was the first guy to realize you
should put the rocks on the image well
everybody realized it
okay rookie eight
okay so um there is technically a threat
of
uh
my opponent taking on f3 and then taking
on e5 but that's not a scary threat
that's just upon i wouldn't worry too
much about protecting every remaining
pawn go instead for the you know see the
bigger picture in such a position
so there's a couple of approaches here
um we could take the knight and then go
like knight c7 and trade everything
but i particularly like the concept of
sticking the bishop on on b5
and attacking the rook
so one of many many good moves
bishop takes f3 is the one move that
needed to be calculated because if
bishop takes f3 there we go
which of the two pieces should we take
should we take the rook here or should
we take back on f3 both are obviously
winning we're not talking about like one
move being winning one not not winning
okay so some of you guys fell for it if
you take the bishop then that very same
rook which is being attacked can take on
e5
but if you calculate concretely if you
take the rook
and then
they take the bishop and we take the
bishop with our rook we're still up a
piece our pieces are still coordinated
uh and we are able to preserve the pawn
on e5
so
i think what may disawait people from
going for this is like the bishop on e8
may seem a little bit awkward and yeah
he attacks the bishop
but don't remember the concept that you
shouldn't be scared of threats just
because they're a threat
threats are not scary because they're
threats threats are scary if you can't
stop them or if they achieve something
so just because a piece is on a slightly
vulnerable square doesn't mean you
should automatically reject the line if
you calculate concretely and you see
that there is no way to actually win
that piece you can safely go for the
line
so bishop d7 why bishop d7 to prevent
him from going rook c8 to keep the rook
confined
uh and the bishop is just like a thorn
in black side
now we can play very nicely to finish
the game how should white proceed
of course there are better options than
meekly trading the knights
one proposal is to begin with the move
bishop c5 check activating the bishop
and then to stick the knight on this
weak square on b6 continuing
to twist the knife in and if rook ba we
can make a really cute move black is
going to be completely paralyzed after
that move we can immobilize the knight
with bishop to d6
so this is really nice this is a kind of
a
an easy conversion it's very easy to
make good moves in a position like this
but still okay rook a6 how should we win
the game here
here there is a crushing move on the
spot
noticing that the rook x-rays the bishop
if we take the bishop it's a backranker
discovery with this bishop where should
we go bishop e5 is very easy
um attacking the rook
okay he's got to move the bishop into
science yeah
nice game
so
openings like the alakan
are very risky precisely for this reason
particularly at a level where white is
likely to know what to do
um
they're potentially high risk and high
reward openings if you know the alakan
very very well you can win a lot of
games in it you can get good positions
but if you
forget a single line or you don't study
it too well
you could end up suffering and being
miserable and struggling basically every
game because
objectively speaking black's position is
quite dubious and so in order to
compensate for that you got to know the
theory very well
adaptating for the prime so my advice
would be if you're willing to invest a
lot of time into learning your black
openings
openings such as the allokine could be
something to consider if you're 18 1900.
um but you've got to be okay with
playing cramped positions where your
opponent is a big center some people
kind of like that i kind of like that so
i have played the alaka in my share of
times
it is a very sharp opening for the most
part but some lines can be very
positional just like the sicilian is the
sicilian a sharp opening it depends
which line
uh some sicilians can be very positional
most sicilians yes are are definitely on
the tactical side
so d4d6
there is a plethora of good lines to
play against the alakan
um
knight f3
is considered was considered for a long
time to be sort of the cool one
i think recently
no but it's still good i mean knight f3
definitely gives an edge
d595
one of the craziest lines in the alakin
uh continues knight to d7 this is an old
move trying to trade the knights i mean
does anybody know
what incredible tactical option exists
for white here this doesn't win this is
a theoretical line it leads to an
incredibly messy position
yeah so knight takes f7 king f7
and queen h5 check for king the king and
the queen king of the knight but the
king steps into e6 defending the knight
and you get into a completely chaotic
just total pandemonium on the board as
white tries to hunt the king around the
entire board
this is a very entertaining line so you
can dig around yourself
you can look this up
knight d7 is not particularly common
this doesn't occur too often anymore i
don't know what the current theoretical
evaluation is i think it might be a draw
c4
uh so there is a four strike why can
play queen g4 and repeat moves like this
um
but if if i think the main move here
is c4 yeah c4 knight f6 d5 king d6
and you get this position boom boom boom
boom the queen slides into f7
threatening to go to e6
and the line goes on it's totally crazy
you can investigate this yourself this
is a little outside the scope of the
speed run
um
so that's one move and the other set of
lines is either c4 e takes d6 and here
black has both c takes d6 and e takes d6
uh cd6 is the more tactical line it it
creates a pawn structure in balance
because obviously it gives white a
majority on the queen side gives black a
central majority
e takes d6 is more tame
keeps the pawn structure balanced
expedites the development of the bishop
but it's also a little bit more passive
um
you know this is pretty easy to invest
i'm sure there are youtube videos you
could find that that
give you an overview
um but we decided to go for the
principled f4
so de5 fe 5 knight c6 bishop e3 that's
the main line again if knight f3 bishop
g4 and now you play bishop e3
i think this is possible i don't think
this
i don't think this loses
uh but black is a very nasty move here
you can just take the knight
i think that's the move let me check no
no e6 first
e6 first
and it's just that this additional
burden
is very hard to handle
uh because at any point black could take
the knight and basically force you to
take with the pawn ruining your
structure it's just that um
it's just the white center gets under a
lot of pressure this is unnecessary you
can play bishop e3 first this move has
no downsides
and what you're basically doing is
playing a cat and mouse game
which consists of the following black
has to develop the bishop sooner or
later you can't delay this forever
if you play e6 and try to develop the
other bishop well then you block the
bishop in the first place
and
you cannot procrastinate with
development you can't afford to do that
when white has such a center and so only
after bishop f5 do you play knight f3
that's a common technique in many
openings where you want to avoid an
unpleasant scenario is you just simply
develop your other pieces first
and the moment your opponent makes a
move
then
you do whatever you wanted to do and in
order to create that unpleasant scenario
they have to lose a tempo i don't know
if i just made sense
uh but that's the bottom line
bishop b7 bishop b2 castles castles and
a5 i think is a big mistake
um as i said the main line is f6
e takes f6 bishop f6 and you get this
very interesting position
white generally goes if i remember
correctly queen to d2
then
rook a to d1 just securing the d4 pump
black does the same thing queen e7
you know rook d1 with d8 white is better
my white is slightly better nice nice
center
uh very good piece coordination but
black has you know black has his share
of of
of active play and there are people who
know these positions very very well for
black
um
but if anybody has any questions this
this is a pretty easy to understand
position there's nothing crazy that's
going on here
so
anyways f6 is the move
but a5 is is too slow this doesn't
address
white's monster center
and moreover the moment this move is
played i pay attention to this knight on
v6 this knight on b6 is now a little bit
more loose
and as it turns out the c7 pawn plays a
very important role
of acting as a foil to the d-pawn and so
that's why we played the move d5 d5
knight before bishop b6
and of course c takes v6 whoops not this
move but cb6 keeps black in the game d6
and he can put the bishop on g5
um i think the best sequence for white
is definitely to take this bishop and
after queen takes g5 to play a very
important move
who can spot this is a good positional
question for you guys this is not a
tactic not a tactic it's a positional
move and it's a
and it's a good positional move who can
uh
who has a guess about what to do
okay so
i'm seeing nobody said the move so far
nobody said the move so far
okay so let me give you guys a hint
yes master troll god got it it's the
move is queen c1 and i just verified
this with the engine so i'm not making
this up
um now let me explain why first thing
you have to do in this position is
identify the threat
and when you're identifying the threat
and a piece of advice i gave earlier is
not to
rush not to rush this process
um it's not often it's not always as
easy
to identify the threat as it appears in
addition there might be more than one
threat that's the case here there's more
than one threat
the first threat
is queen e3 check forking the king in
this very important e5 pawn
so you could try to defend against that
by let's say dropping the king to h1
but there is a second threat i'm
noticing that the queen and rook are in
a forkable position
this knight on b4 is also quite
dangerous as we've discussed so he's got
the move knight c2 rook c1 and the
knight swings around to e3
this is a devastating fork because not
only are we forking the rook of the
queen but also checkmate is threatened
white loses the queen
so
what you want to do is find a move that
both defends against knight c2 and
defends against queen e3 so we must take
this square under control that's why
queen c1 accomplishes all of these
things obviously defends e3 and in the
event of a queen trade the value of a
pass pawn increases in the end game as
you guys know intuitively particularly
the value of
of a
protected passer
if black tries to go knight c6
uh and
win the pawn
then what we can do here is we can
counter attack the b6 pawn we can go
knight a4
and in a very funny sequence
we get another protected pass spawn but
this time the c5 pawn is a lot more
robust white is just winning here the
pawns are overwhelming
so queen c1 i think is a very nice move
um remember that you can kind of
weaponize the queen trade sometimes
queen trades don't mean
you want to get into a boring endgame
sometimes the queen trade is the only
vehicle
to keep your advantage
rook f3 some people suggested i think
that's probably a good move
but what i'd be worried about here is
something like bishop g6
now this e5 pawn is incredibly weak so
in addition i'm not sure you've
addressed the question of knight c2 and
knight e3
um
well yeah you're right vp so
you mean after an ic2 queen and quincy
one yeah that's true queen c1 probably
does defend
uh against the immediate threats
something i didn't notice at first but
still i mean
i can move my queen away
and the knight is protected so
but you're right now queen c1 is a very
important resource
uh so i would just add that this bishop
g6 idea is another
reason why you want to eliminate black's
queen because of the pressure on e5 and
you could end up losing this pawn
so good bye good catch about knight c2
so knight c2 might not be like
a threat in the strictest sense uh but
it's something that could happen to you
if you like if you play queen d4
then i go knight c2 and i win the
exchange
so i hope this makes sense um after ed
bishop f2 the game is over there's
really nothing to talk about here we
just won the pawn
traded queens and got our pieces into
the game and
and the rest was the rest was easy
any questions about this game
[Music]